wir kommen zu unserem nächsten fall ein
fall den jeder kennt hier in deutschland
und auch vor allem ihr gesicht kennt das
gesicht von rebecca sie war das ja
glückliche kind das strahlende lächeln
der sonnenschein in ihrer familie und in
diesen tagen da wäre rebecca neusch 18
jahre alt geworden aber rebecca ist seit
zweieinhalb jahren spurlos verschwunden
die ermittler gehen davon aus dass der
schwanebecker ermordet und dann in einem
wald verscharrt hat wir haben uns auf
spurensuche begeben unser reporter
matthias becker guten morgen und bei uns
liegen diese gegenstände die ebenso
wichtig sind in diesem fall eine
sozusagen gleiche lila decke und der
rucksack der rebecca bei sich hatte
vielleicht erinnern sich menschen an
diese gegenstände aber lasst uns gleich
rein gehen im fall matthias wir haben es
gehört die ermittler die glauben das ist
der schwager war und dennoch können sie
es ihm nicht nachweisen wie kann das
sein na ja das ist ja das problem immer
ein mord ohne leiche
das ist schon mal ganz schwierig da den
nachweis zu führen und die polizei muss
eben beweissichere festnahmen tätigen
und die müssen beweise sammeln und die
haben sie in diesem fall eben einfach
nicht der schwager selbst der hat in den
vernehmungen ist hat er gar nichts
gesagt hat er es
geleugnet was er wie reagiert der der
schwanger hat am anfang natürlich wurde
er als zeuge befragt und dann hat er
auch bereits fertig geäußert wie was da
am abend oder am morgen war er war ja in
der nacht noch zu einer betriebsfeier
und das hat ja alles geschildert und
erst als die beamten dann mitbekommen
haben dass da widersprüche sind und ihr
auch gelogen hat das schloss sich der
kreis und da wurde er zum
hauptbeschuldigten und dann bekam er
auch diesen haftbefehlen wir haben jetzt
gesehen diese autobahn nach brandenburg
gibt es die möglichkeit dass man in
brandenburg einmal für leute die nicht
von hier kommen kann man dort wirklich
eine leiche so verschwinden lassen dass
man sie nicht mehr findet brandenburg
ist ein flächenstaat und das ist
unglaublich viel ansehen ein morast fast
sympathisch ich war ja draußen die haben
ja alle gesucht wir waren ja auch da
nochmal und zu haben geguckt das ist
schier unmöglich spüren der
leichenspürhunde infrarot kameras mit
hubschraubern es hat alles nichts
geholfen und gibt es ganz vielleicht
noch die möglichkeit dass das mädchen
einfach weggelaufen ist das ist so
unwahrscheinlich weil sie sehr
bodenständig war sie hat eine intakte
familie ein gutes elternhaus
es gibt nichts
was es
erklären lassen könnte dass sie jetzt
freiwillig ihr lebensumfeld verlassen
hat
[Musik]